from ryan gosling and emma stone to tom
hanks and meg ryan
it's hard to believe some on-screen
couples aren't together in real life
with undeniable chemistry these co-stars
have flirted their way through many
films together while making us believe
in true love anne hathaway and jake
gyllenhaal are real-life best friends
jennifer lawrence and bradley cooper
bicker like a married couple
and keanu reeves and sandra bullock had
huge crushes on each other
here are some of the best on-screen
couples who have brought passion to
multiple movies and how they feel about
each other behind the scenes
kiss me what public displays of
affection make people very uncomfortable
yes i do
according to emma stone ryan gosling was
the king of twizzlers on the set of la
la land
he'd eat them all day and fill his
pockets with them guess this is just one
of the weird things you learn about a
costar when you've been in so many
movies together
they were a steamy couple in crazy
stupid love and tore up the screen
together again
in gangster squad but la la land is the
movie that comes to mind when you think
about the perfection of this on-screen
duo
director damian chazelle said that their
chemistry is one for the ages and
compared them to fred astaire and ginger
rogers
emma says this bond goes all the way
back to the audition for crazy stupid
love
when they instantly had an unspoken
understanding now she's the first to say
that she can't even imagine what her
life would be like
if ryan wasn't in it so you're not quite
big enough to be [ __ ]
i give up what's your racket handsome
jake gyllenhaal describes anne hathaway
as brilliant adventurous and one of the
most talented actresses of their
generation
brokeback mountain was their first movie
together and jake insists he
automatically knew that he and anne
would do more amazing things together
when love and other drugs came along
saying yes was a no-brainer
and describes jake is curious reliable a
true family man
and he's also her mentor but not in
acting instead
she goes to him whenever she needs
cooking advice i'm sorry
i know it's so late oh my god oh my god
when woody allen needed an acting duo
for his new movie he turned to an
unlikely source
wedding crashers after seeing rachel
mcadams and owen wilson fall in love
he decided they'd be the perfect fit for
a movie that wasn't quite so
lighthearted
midnight in paris isn't exactly the
comedy that wedding crashers is
but rachel and owen have an undeniable
chemistry and they have their shared
love of comedy to thank
the duo has admitted they don't hang out
much between films but their
professional relationship is like a work
marriage
and owen really only has one thing to
say when asked about what he thinks
about rachel
wow jennifer lawrence says she and
bradley cooper bicker all the time
like a married couple but she wouldn't
trade her best acting partner for anyone
else
bradley attributes their steamy
on-screen chemistry to the long hours
spent learning dance moves for silver
linings playbook
and it was during that filming that
jayla decided to sign on for
serena the pair have also starred in
american hustle and joy
and whether they're on-screen love
interests or not jennifer has joked that
she always starts a new project by
asking if bradley cooper will be in it
keep your voice down i'm just the crazy
[ __ ]
with a dead husband we've all dreamed
about being matthew mcconaughey's love
interest but kate hudson has surprising
thoughts from working with the hollywood
heartthrob
she says he's not the best kisser and
that their kiss at the end of fool's
gold was
actually pretty gross there was a lot of
water and apparently some snot involved
in that kiss
definitely not as dreamy as it looked on
screen but still there's only love
between the two co-stars who say they've
been like siblings since they starred
and how to lose a guy in 10 days
mcconaughey describes kate as
fun and rock and roll which seems like a
glowing endorsement from the cinematic
legend
are we gonna die no no we're not
amy adams says christian bale always
inspires her to bring her performance to
another level
and she has a ton of fun yelling at him
in movies it might even be her good luck
charm when it comes to their multiple
oscar-nominated films
speaking of those nominations the
on-screen couple has shared a lot of
success together
they were both oscar nominees in the
same years for their roles in vice
american hustle and the fighter at this
point the pair working together again
is just inevitable i felt like we had a
secret
just the two of us some on-screen
co-stars are married in real life and
one of the best examples is melissa
mccarthy and ben falcone
they first met at a little improv
theater in la but they got their big
break when they both appeared in
bridesmaids the duo also wrote and
starred in
life of the party ben even had to direct
a love scene between his wife and
another guy
and it was filmed on their real-life
anniversary ben admits he gets a little
jealous sometimes
but who wouldn't be when your wife is
making out with a college student
i don't have a gun for you to put up my
ass to make sure you enjoy my nano
i will show you another ultra talented
on-screen pair is julia roberts and
george clooney who first met at a hotel
before filming ocean's 11
back in 2000. despite their first
meeting being kind of romantic
the pair has only ever been friends
clooney and matt damon used to play
pranks on julia on set
but during ocean's 12 she was pregnant
so instead her co-star took it upon
himself to wait on her hand and
foot the pair teamed up again for august
osage county
and money monster and their films
together have made over
one billion dollars at the box office as
for their real-life romance
julia is a huge fan of george clooney's
wife amal
so there's no unrequited affections for
this on-screen couple
the soundtrack of george's life yeah
listen you wouldn't recognize me if you
didn't hear this
drew barrymore and adam sandler are best
friends drew even ranked sandler as her
most talented co-star
over hugh grant and jake gyllenhaal from
the wedding singer to 50 first dates and
blended
they're constantly making each other
laugh sometimes so much that it's hard
to finish a scene
drew presented sandler with a best actor
award for uncut gems and he thanked her
in his speech by saying
i'm glad we met i'm glad we did it all
and we always make our movies together
they describe each other as best buds
and it's a friendship that we would love
to be a part of
are you okay i'll be right back
after alan rickman passed away his
co-star and close friend
emma thompson wrote a moving tribute to
him she praised his humor
intelligence wisdom and kindness and
said he was the ultimate ally
i trusted him absolutely he was above
all things
a rare and unique human being if that
doesn't make you tear up
then looking at their history together
will they were both in harry potter
sense and sensibility and judas kiss but
their most romantic
moments together are from love actually
for them being in love on screen was
like breathing
and emma will always cherish that
irreplaceable bond
slightly special personal one thank you
that's a real first dak shepard and
kristen bell are married in real life
the first time they played romantic love
interests was in hit and run
and their dialogue was inspired by their
real-life conversations as a married
couple
both kristen and dax admit to fighting
but they always find a way to get past
it kristin said she used to run out of
the house during a fight but dax helped
her learn how to communicate better
it's this type of collaboration that's
had them work on films like chips
together
and their talent for making each other
laugh has led to golden comedies
like when in rome this is crazy i don't
know whether to look at my own
reflection or at you that's how
beautiful you are
during separate interviews with ellen
degeneres keanu reeves and sandra
bullock revealed that they had crushes
on each other while filming 1994's speed
the only thing is neither of them knew
the other had a crush if they could go
back in time
the lake house stars would probably have
dated maybe they'd even have gotten
married
but that's all in the past now and
sandra and keanu have decided to stick
to being best friends
you didn't leave me didn't have anywhere
to be just then
they don't often play romantic love
interests but johnny depp and helena
bonham carter are the mascots for
amazing
on-screen chemistry a lot of their
connection comes from them being so
similar
they feel it's easier to get into a
character when they have elaborate
costumes and they also agree that
they're both
kind of crazy they start in dark shadows
alice in wonderland
and even the corpse bride but sweeney
todd is the movie that found them in a
dysfunctional romance
helena admits that it's weird for her
then husband director tom burton to see
her making out with depp
who is one of his best friends but
despite some awkward moments
their friendship is eternal what if i
take off your head will you know then
stop that tom hanks and meg ryan are
rom-com perfection
and they've remained friends since their
first movie together 1990s joe versus
the volcano
meg is part of the reason tom eventually
agreed to do sleepless in seattle
and she describes the actor as one of
the best in the business
and someone who is always rooting for
others meanwhile
tom praises her as being very smart and
always keeping him on his toes
you've got mail will always be iconic
because of the passion these two share
on the big screen and my breath catches
in my chest until i hear
three little words scarlett johansson
and chris evans have an on-screen
relationship that goes beyond the mcu
they both appeared in the perfect score
and shared some love
in the nanny diaries the co-stars
finally pleased marvel fans when nat
and cap shared a quick kiss in winter
soldier but the actress described
themselves as brother and sister
johansson says the chemistry comes from
knowing her co-star more than a decade
and having such a fun time working
together doesn't hurt
he's so uncomfortable it's not exactly
the word i would use
which of these on-screen couples is your
favorite do you have a favorite that we
missed
let us know in the comments don't forget
to hit that like button and subscribe to
the things for more
thanks for watching